good afternoon
good afternoon masters Dean's colleagues
friends and the class of 2017 my name is
Marisol gentry and I'm a senior
associate dean of Yale College Dean of
Student Affairs and Dean of freshmen
affairs on behalf of all of my
colleagues in Yale College I'd like to
welcome you to this orientation keynote
address and this the very first time
you've all been in the same place as a
class congratulations
at this time I ask that you disable all
cellphones and electronic devices thank
you and now it gives me great pleasure
to introduce Mary Miller the Dean of
Yale College and sterling professor of
history of art this past Saturday you
all had the opportunity to hear Dean
Miller when she gave her freshman
Assembly address now I'd like to tell
you a bit about her before taking on the
deanship Dean Miller served as master of
Sabre at college for nearly a decade
until she became Dean of Yale College in
2008 Dean Miller has served as chair of
the department of history of art chair
of the Council on Latin American Studies
director of Graduate Studies in
archaeological studies and as a member
of the steering committee of the women
faculty forum at Yale Dean Miller is the
pre-eminent scholar of the art of the
ancient new world for her work on
ancient Mexico and the Maya Dean Miller
has won national recognition including a
Guggenheim Fellowship she was elected to
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences in 1994 she is scheduled to
deliver the Slade lectures at Cambridge
University during the academic year
2014-2015 serving as the Dean of Yale
College is a major undertaking and Dean
Miller has led progressively and
expertly with character dignity and
grace my colleagues and I often marvel
at how she's able to stay on top of her
games scholastically while serving as
dean of Yale College but she has having
completed several major book projects
since becoming Dean her latest book
entitled the spectacle of the late Maya
Court reflections on the murals of
Bonampak arrived at our office a few
days a few weeks ago scuse me it already
has been Dean destined to become a
standard reference for future
scholarship on the pivotal role of
images in the highly charged political
atmosphere of the late classic mile
round
this very important book also has been
labeled a masterful culmination of over
30 years of Dean Miller's engagement
with these paintings Dean Miller has
many interests she's often spotted on
campus attending student plays concerts
and sporting events of all kind she's an
avid squash player and she also enjoys
baking delicious goodies and knitting
very beautiful garments I hope that you
all get to know Dean Miller during your
time here at Yale I now ask her to come
to introduce our speaker
I'm stepping on the stool and bringing
down the microphone
welcome 2017 I just feel as though I saw
so many of you at the academic fair over
the past couple of hours and it's been a
wonderful afternoon to walk around and
speak with students in who are meeting
with directors of undergraduate studies
and then out on the sidewalks as you're
thinking about the smorgasbord of Yale
that lies ahead of you
I'd like to invite you to if you have if
you're wearing a jacket or a sweater if
you'd like to take a second to remove it
it you might be more comfortable here
because it is so much hotter than it was
on Saturday when we last met in this
room do I have any takers
Thanks I know you'll be a little bit
more comfortable and it is a sticky
afternoon but we fortunately have
provided this rather stiff piece of
paper which seems to have come in quite
handy it's my great pleasure to
introduce Professor Tamar Sabo Gendler
she's the vincent's J's skully professor
of philosophy
she's chair of the Department of
Philosophy and now I'm about to give you
a list that I think I I hope I promise
not to quiz you on but just think about
it she's professor of philosophy
professor of humanities professor of
cognitive science and professor of
psychology how did you get there well
professor and you'll notice that I just
used the word professor not doctor most
faculty in Hale College are known not by
the medical term which we tend to
reserved for people who have MD after
their name
professor Kendler started her career
just as you did on a hot sticky week in
New Haven possibly wondering like you
where the road ahead would lead well
after she graduated and yes in
continuing a series of shoutouts she was
in Pearson college
and she had a double major in philosophy
in humanities rather a new major that
had just been born at the time that she
was a student here and the the joint
major of mathematics and philosophy that
road led her after Yale eventually and
we forgive her that she went to Harvard
for her PhD which she earned in
philosophy after Harvard she went home
to teach other places before coming back
to Yale in 2006 I'm always touched by
the fact that she spent part of a most
of a decade in my home stomping grounds
of upstate New York teaching at Syracuse
in Cornell she came back in 2006 and she
has been making wonderful waves ever
since
professor Gendler studies philosophical
psychology epistemology now I have to
look at my list metaphysics and
aesthetics and she often writes about
the beliefs between the differences
between the beliefs we think we hold and
the ones we actually hold now it may
turn out that some of you have already
watched part of her all of her lectures
on open Yale so you already have some
idea of what she might say to you but
let me just add that this work has won
major prizes and awards and she is right
now in this moment the most cited woman
philosopher under the age of 50 this is
an extraordinary achievement
that's not on her CV yet but she has to
be very careful what she says to me you
never know where that information is
going to turn up next
last year the students in Yale College
nominated her for the Sidonie Miskimmin
prize for excellence in teaching in the
humanities it's one of the university's
highest distinctions and a mark of one
of you of being one of Yale's great
teachers but you might have guessed this
already from the name attached to hers
she's the Vincent Scully professor and
the Vincent Scully professorship was
established in 1998 by members of the
class of 1958 in honor of the professor
who had made their lives so who had
changed their lives so much by the way
he taught them to they sought to honor
him and there have only been three
Vincent Scully professors and I'm kind
of touched to say that I was the first
one we won't mention the second and
tomorrow is the third so it's very nice
to be able to offer this link between us
as you start on this road yourselves you
may be wondering where the path will
take you you're going to have plenty of
time to answer that question but what
you'll learn in the next few days and
over the next few years is that you'll
find excellent guides wherever you look
for them this afternoon's speaker one of
Yale's most accomplished scholars and
teachers is one of those guides are your
pockets empty are your contradictions
there I don't have any pockets so I but
please I'm just thinking I have no
pockets this afternoon maybe that's a
good thing but I know you will join me
in welcoming our guest in as she turns
to her address keeping contradiction in
your pockets
professor Gendler
thank you so much Dean Gentry thank you
so much Dean Miller and welcome welcome
welcome members of the class of 2017
as a proud member of the Yale College
class of 1987 I welcome you to the best
reunion cohort ever the twos and the
seventh welcome aboard can you believe
you're here I mean it really look around
you you're sitting in Woolsey Hall on
the campus of Yale University
surrounded by 1359 of the most amazing
and engaging and exciting young people
on the planet you hail from all 50
states and from 49 different countries
you're from Argentina and Bulgaria and
China and there's no one from Denmark or
Djibouti but you're from Ethiopia and
France and Ghana and Hong Kong and India
and Japan and don't worry and Senegal
and Trinidad and the United Arab
Emirates though no one from Yemen or
Zimbabwe you play the violin and the
marimba and the gamelan and the electric
guitar
you've won math competitions and poetry
prizes you've built award-winning
haunted houses and toured with teams of
professional clowns you've tended
Gardens you've worked on oil rigs you've
organized peace protests you've served
in the Navy you class of 2017 are an
extraordinarily diverse group look
around the room again this is a room
full of people who will become your
classmates for the next four years and
your friends for the next 40 this is a
place where your predecessors have sat
and your successors will sit
and this is a space like so many other
spaces on this magnificent sometimes
overwhelming sometimes intimidating
often magical campus that is yours to
explore yours to learn from yours to
transform and yours to make your own so
to set you out on the path of making
this space your own let me honor the
person for whom my chair was named and
tell you a little bit about the building
where you're sitting
Woolsey Hall that is this space is one
of a trio of buildings known as the
Bicentennial buildings these buildings
were built as the name suggests to honor
the bicentennial of Yale in 1901 and
they were the very first buildings on
this campus that belonged to Yale as a
university as a whole rather than to one
of Yale's constituent units the
Sheffield scientific school the Yale
College the Yale Law School and so on
their goal was to provide for the campus
the first large-scale secular gathering
space a space where the entire community
could assemble on common neutral ground
Woolsey Hall this grand soaring space of
coming together was named in honor in
honor of Theodore Dwight Woolsey who was
president of Yale from 1846 to 1871 and
who had died in 1899 just two years
before the Bicentennial buildings were
commemorated Wolsey had been a
transformative figure in Yale's history
a scholar of Greek he was known to his
colleagues as a man of original and
creative scholarly powers he'd spent
time abroad at German universities of
the era
and when he returned to America he was
committed to bringing the rigors of
classical education to the young men of
New Haven so the members of the class of
1902 who would have sat in this room
when it was brand-new
these are contemporaries roughly of your
great-great-great grandparents would
have recognized along the ceiling here
the images of the nine Muses who grace
the ceiling
these are melpomene II the muse of
tragedy Calliope
the muse of epic poetry Polyhymnia the
muse of the sacred you tear pay who
inspires music Erato who inspires the
lyrics of love Thalia the muse of comedy
or Anya the muse of astronomy Cleo the
muse of history terpsichore the muse of
dance and at the center Athena goddess
of wisdom the goal of the architects who
designed this room the same team who
went on to design the New York Public
Library
a decade later was to create a space
where myth and reality past and present
come together with the universality of
human experience is evoked through the
magic of music and the grandeur of the
heavens the other two buildings in the
Bicentennial trio of structures are also
places of coming together
the Yale Commons dining hall with its
Hogwarts beings and it's long communal
tables it's designed as a place of
gathering a place where affiliations
fall away and the memorial Rotunda that
grand circular fulcrum that joins
Commons to Woolsey Hall the hinge
connects Science Hill to the downtown
campus that space is even more power Li
powerfully a place where past and
present are joined engraved on the walls
of that rotunda through which you will
pass almost daily in your time at Yale
are the names of the students and alumni
who died as soldiers in each of
America's wars over the last two
centuries from the Revolutionary War in
the 1770s to the Vietnam War two
centuries later Maya Lin on the 1981
graduate who inspired by that space
designed the Vietnam War Memorial in
Washington DC writes of the power of
passing through those hallways she says
I have never been able to resist
touching those names cut into the marble
walls no matter how busy or crowded the
place is a sense of quiet of reverence
always surrounds those names some of you
may feel these spaces in the ways that
I'm describing them you may feel
comfortable even uplifted by the grand
towering symbol Laden formality of these
rooms and halls others of you may find
them overwhelming even intimidating you
may feel the exclusionary weight of
Yale's massive wooden doors and its
heavy iron gates
you may feel discomfort navigating an
unfamiliar place imbued with the markers
of traditional privilege you may be
profoundly aware that many of us in this
room including all three of us on this
stage would not have been
admitted to Yale in its early years Yale
is indeed a work in progress and there
is much progress still to be made both
of these ways of responding to the
campus the feeling of welcome and the
feeling of anxiety are legitimate both
are important and the capacity for both
is inside all of you there's an inch
Jewish teaching that says that every
human being should carry in their
pockets two pieces of paper on one of
them you should write the words for my
sake was the world created and on the
other you should write I am but dust and
ashes
the teaching continues by telling you to
reach for each of these papers at the
moment that you're feeling the opposite
so when you're feeling lowly or
depressed or discouraged or overwhelmed
you should pull from your pocket the
paper that says the world was created
for my sake and when you're feeling high
and mighty superior and arrogant you
should pull from your pocket
the paper that says dust and ashes are
all that I am you will find all of you
the need for both of these papers during
your time at Yale there will be moments
when you will be convinced that you do
not belong here that you are hopeless
fraud that the admissions office made a
terrible mistake
in not eliminating your application in
the very first round and for moments
like that one you need to create for
yourself something that does what that
first
of paper says that is something that
reminds you that you do indeed belong
here that Yale was created for your sake
and that if you are feeling overwhelmed
or out of place or lonely or isolated
that this entire community this room
full of your amazing classmates the
upper-class students that you will meet
in your colleges and classrooms and in
your singing groups and on your athletic
teams the campus staff that files and
cleans and cooks and guards the graduate
students and faculty who will join you
in your seminars and laboratories and
field sites and studios the librarians
the coaches the cooks the counselors the
doctors the deans and the masters we are
here for you for your sake was this
campus community created but of course
though the campus community was created
for you
it was also created for you and for you
and for you and for you and for you it
was created for you as a plural vosotros
in Spanish Flu in French Suzie in
Turkish y'all in Alabama for you and me
and him and her and them and us for all
of us and that's where the second piece
of paper comes in the second piece of
paper reminds you that you are but dust
and ashes that is that you are composed
of the same matter as your fellow
creatures and that you like them are
transient inhabitant of this planet you
were made of the same materials dust and
ashes protons and electrons hydrogen and
helium cells and more cells as every
other living being so when at the moment
that
first piece of paper has raised you so
far above those around you that you
begin to lose your sense of commonality
with them your sense of connectedness to
them your sense of responsibility for
them it's time for the second piece of
paper dust and ashes is all that you are
so that's one pair of inconsistencies
that you can keep in your pockets to
guide you during your time at Yale but
there's another pair inspired by the
first that I've already mentioned that I
also advise you to keep on hand so
here's another version of the parable
every human being should carry in their
pockets two pieces of paper on one of
them you should write the words all
others experience the world as I do and
on the other you should write my
perspective is mine alone there are
moments that you will need to pull each
of these from your pockets there are
times when you will assume too much
commonality with those around you and
times when you will assume too little
the asite ssin that everyone's
experience is the same as my own it's
the classic mistake of infancy a baby
who has covered her eyes so that she
can't see you is profoundly convinced
that you can't see her it's a major
developmental milestone typically
reached only at the age of four or so to
recognize that somebody else's beliefs
could differ from your own but the task
remains a difficult one even for adults
a standard task in psychology studies
involves sitting people to people on
opposite side
of a table so I would be on this side
and you would be on that one and putting
between us a vertical sort of
tic-tac-toe board made out of shelves
that forms a grid on which different
objects are placed so between us would
be a kind of crisscross and in each of
the cells 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 would be
placed a different object so for example
there might be a small rubber duck in
this cell in a medium rubber duck in
that one and a small stuffed bear in the
third and so on if you're having trouble
visualizing this scenario to some extent
I've already made my point when you have
a picture in your head a perspective on
the world that you're trying to share
with someone else it's incredibly
difficult to figure out just what you
have to tell them to bring them to
understand the image that you're trying
to convey in this case is no exception
but I'm hoping that at least a few of
you have some sort of picture in your
mind of this setup since I want to
describe for you the rest of the
experiment I promise that it has
something to do with the second two
pieces of paper and I promise that even
if you aren't following the details the
point will still be clear the way the
study continues is by giving one of the
subjects instructions to tell the other
subject to do something so for example
you might be told to say to me take the
large rubber duck out of itself and put
it on the table beside the tic-tac-toe
board and my job is simply to do what
you've asked me to do sounds pretty easy
but there's something about the setup
which I didn't tell you yet which is
that some of the cells are blocked out
on one of their side by a little piece
of opaque cardboard so for example the
center cell might be visible to me
but not to you and I would know that
because I could see behind the object
that I see in the center sell the
occluding piece of cardboard that
prevents you from seeing for example the
large rubber duck that's in that center
cell so I might realize that although
from my perspective there are three
rubber ducks a small one a medium one
and a large one from yours there are
only two since the large one is blocked
from your view what this means is that I
should realize that when you say take
the large rubber duck out of its cell
and put it on the table you mean that I
should take what I think of as the
medium rubber duck and put it on the
table
if I'm understanding your words in the
way that you are using them I should
move the duck that I think is the medium
one because I know that that's the duck
that you think is large it turns out
that this simple task is awfully hard to
do children are terrible at it and even
adults even adults who say to themselves
what you can see and what I can see tend
to reach first for the wrong object and
correct themselves only along the way
and if you distract them by having them
do some other tasks at the same time
they are just as bad as children the
story has several morals the first and
simplest is that rubber ducks come in
all sorts of sizes the second which I
already mentioned is that it's awfully
difficult to describe something to
someone else so that they understand
clearly what you're trying to describe
even when what
trying to say is vividly clear in your
own mind and the third and most
important is that our natural tendency
in many circumstances to assume that
others share our perspective on the
world that they are just like us that we
don't need to correct for what is
idiosyncratic in our experiences may be
profoundly mistaken
of course we're consciously aware of all
sorts of differences among us
consciously I may realize that you watch
MSNBC while I prefer Fox that you think
Edward Snowden is a hero while I think
he's a criminal that you are obsessed
with opera while I'm obsessed with
base-jumping that you love to dance
Kathakali while I prefer to twerk
I will not
but when we're engaged in real-time
moment-to-moment interactions we may
lose track of the ways that we are
assuming commonality where there may be
difference I may assume tacitly through
neglecting to mention it that because my
gender identity matches the biological
sex that I was assigned at Birth that
yours does too you may assume tacitly by
not mentioning it that because your life
takes its meaning and structure from a
religious tradition that mine does too
you may assume tacitly that just because
you think our interaction is a fully
consensual one that I do too and I may
assume tacitly that because I intend
this address to be inclusive and
welcoming that you are experiencing it
in that way in fact I almost made
exactly that mistake I thought how
wonderful it would be to welcome the
members a Pearson college to Yale
University
and then I realized that I was leaving
out eleven tenths of the rooms to
Berkeley and Branford and Calhoun and
Davenport a thousand
so that's why you need that little piece
of paper in your pocket the one that
says assume that my perspective is mine
alone sometimes using Wii is a way of
being inclusive we're all in this
together
but sometimes it's a way of tacitly
excluding and excluding in the most
painful way because it doesn't involve
the acknowledgement of exclusion we
think thus and such we feel so and so
that we like this room may have
different meanings for different people
so take that perspective piece of paper
from your pocket when you are trying to
genuinely listen and genuinely speak
realize that you may be assuming
commonality when there's actually
diversity that you may be assuming
consensus when there's actually dissent
open yourself to the possibility that
there are novel perspectives to be
gained from your classmates from the
historical works that you read from
multiple disciplines that provide you
with differing approaches to questions
that matter if your perspective is yours
alone
there is much to be learned from the
perspectives of others at the same time
that assumption of difference may go too
far Yale is filled as I mentioned
earlier with teams of people who are
here for you professors and masters and
Dean's librarians and coaches and
counselors secretaries and janitors and
dining hall staff we are here for you
but we are here for you as fellow human
beings as a team of individuals engaged
alongside you in a joint ender
of tending and building and sustaining
this incredible campus and the community
that it supports and we like you are
dust and ashes protons and electrons
cells and more cells if it's a snowy
winter morning and you pass a member of
the grounds crew who's shoveling the
sidewalk and you're feeling cold she's
probably feeling cold to look her in the
eye and thank her if you walk into your
dining hall greet the workers who cook
your meals learn the names of those who
clean your hallways thank those who file
your forms this is what the second piece
of paper is for to prevent you from
losing track of the humanity of those
around you so keep those pairs of
inconsistencies in your pocket for my
sake alone was the world created I am
but dust and ashes my perspective is
mine alone all others experience the
world as I do and when the circumstances
require pull them from your pockets and
read them aloud to yourself Yale is
yours
all of yours to explore yours to learn
from yours to transform yours to make
your own and we are here for you all of
you welcome class of 2017
Thank You professor Gendler for those
inspiring thought-provoking words
appreciate it and now as a part of this
gathering we'd like to introduce you to
a long-standing Yale tradition the
singing of our alma mater bright college
years you will sing it many times in
your lives as students and then as
alumni so it's fitting that you begin
your Yale career by singing it together
for the very first time as a class the
words and tunes may be unfamiliar right
now but you'll soon learn them by heart
representatives of the Yale glee club
are here today to lead us they will sing
the first verse and then I ask that you
rise and seeing both verses you have
been given a Yale handkerchief it is our
custom to waive it to two from your
right to left on the last line so now
let me call on mr. Jeffery Dalma the
director of the Yale glee club and
members of the Yale glee club they will
be accompanied on the organ by mr. Simon
Jacobs
thank you to the members of the Yale
glee club thank you this now hearing and
concludes our event please now foul out
of Woolsey Hall to your colleges for
your receptions and your dinners thank
you very much